[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young
parent who wants to stop spanking and
transition to different forms of
discipline we also talked to a woman
whose mother changed the wheel and she
wants to know if she should tell her
brother and we talked to a survivor of a
traumatic brain injury that's struggling
with relationships stay tuned
[Music]
what up what's up this is john with the
dr john dolone's show
[Music]
man
every day i think
this world's gone sideways it has gone
absolutely
to the birds
and then it just gets weirder the next
day so here we are
and you decided to top off whatever's
going on in the world with this this
doozy of a podcast i'm so glad that
you're with us hey if you want to be on
the show
we are taking your calls 1-844-693-3291
by we i mean kelly kelly's taking your
calls 1-844-693-3291
um that was the typical male thing where
i'm like yeah we're uh we're pregnant
nope nope we're not we're not
i am not you all right no we're we're
having a baby nope nope no we're not
just just she is so i'm gonna stop by my
head let's go to natasha in mountain
home dude what a cool town hey what's up
natasha
hey how are you thanks for having me
that's cool i like mountain home
mountain home that's like uh never mind
i'm gonna get off i'm gonna get
distracted
we've had some meetings recently where
we've talked about my
distraction uh level so i'm trying to
stay focused so natasha from mountain
home what's up
um well
uh i just wanted some tips i guess on
how to
successfully transition from a
parent who uses spanking as a discipline
method
um you know to a more gentle parenting
method but also you know i feel like
we've kind of set the bar and i don't
really know how do we go back from here
oh man so
what what what what got you rethinking
your approach to discipline
um
yeah what got you thinking
i've heard you talk about it before and
i've seen you know some of the research
about it and
i've been interested in it and i try you
know really hard to
with to be as patient and just you know
just implement the gentle discipline you
know in our house but
i feel like like i said we've got the
ball rolling on you know using spanking
already and i don't know how to
how do we go back yeah so man number one
i applaud you for any time any parent
makes any kind of changes whether it's
this one or
um doing anything differently mid-stream
that's hard right we've created a
context that our kids that's that's what
they know
um and so doing anything differently
like man all we eat is all we eat is his
lucky charms around here and then all of
a sudden you think nope we're switching
to oatmeal then you're gonna have a
rebellion there for a little bit right
like a mutiny
um all right so i want you to take the
word gentle out of your
vocabulary
not um
gentle isn't what we're aiming for
okay okay i want you to um think of we
are with
not over that's the transition we're
making
okay
um
i am no longer going to try to get you
to do things because i've got bigger
muscles than you
right i'm gonna walk alongside you as i
teach you and coach you and instruct you
and hold you
incredibly accountable right which
includes punishment that includes uh
consequences um i'm gonna walk alongside
you as we help you grow up to be
an adult right so here's what i would
recommend
the cornerstone of any sort of
discipline if you will any sort of um
uh
co-responsibility is ownership
the kid has to feel like they are
participating in something bigger than
they are
otherwise they are an actor in your play
they hold no responsibility other than
watch out for swinging fists and sticks
okay
and they will and i'm and you probably
know all this but i'm i'm i want to
to the people who are listening i want
to paint a broader picture
that might mean that they go get
straight a's and they're silent and
they're quiet and they sit still
they can do that because they're part of
a family ecosystem that breathes and
um that breathes together and leans on
one another
or they can do it to avoid getting hit
right right and i want a kid who when
they're 22 knows i do these things
because that's how a neighborhood
operates that's how my community
operates i play a vital role in making
sure that my
country and my neighborhood and my
family is is is doing well it's healthy
right not i want to do these things so i
can avoid
fill in the blank because that leads to
all kind of things downstream so here's
what i would suggest
you probably heard me say this before
but this is a good time to reiterate it
um let's say
your family is the smiths
i would love to see the smith family get
together
and have a big event plan it up bake a
cake make it a big thing i want your
kids to know you get and you gotta how
old your kid
he's seven seven do you have any other
kids
yeah we have a two-year-old as well okay
bring him along and
let the seven-year-old know that his
responsibility is helping the
two-year-old participate right so now
he's got a two-fold he's got a job here
right he's vested
and we're going to create a
we're going to go to like michael's
we're going to go to a hardware store
we're going to get like a like a piece
of plywood we're gonna get some fancy
artsy thing i don't know i've seen some
on the internet people have sent me and
some of them are beautiful
the one we did in our house isn't that
fancy because i'm not that artistic and
my wife is much more than me but we
didn't go that route but
we're gonna create a create a
set of here's who the smith
family is values okay
that will be
you may have some fun with it you're
gonna have a piece of cake you're gonna
laugh you're gonna have a nice dinner
together um is dad around
uh he is but we are actually um
in the process of separating okay all
right so there's going to be a lot of
additional chaos in your home right your
seven-year-old is going to be
additionally untethered in certain ways
so this can be
one of those steps towards it's not
going to be the solution it's going to
be one of the steps towards keeping him
anchored during this separation which is
going to be it's going to be tough on
him right
right so here's who the smiths are we
treat people with respect we are kind we
turn the tv off
at the first whatever the thing is we
listen to one another we
do chores to get whatever the
language is appropriate for the age and
then the transition is this
when you ask your son to do something
okay go pick up your socks and he mouths
off
it is now not you choosing to hit him or
you choosing to
kick him out of the house
you the heartbroken parent
are accepting his choice to no longer be
in the room for the next 10 minutes
you've accepted his choice to not go to
the birthday party this weekend
you've accepted his decision because he
chose to violate the values he got to
choose
not to fill in the blank with whatever
consequences you all decide
it does help if you participate some in
these consequences okay so if you have
ice cream or something dinner and one of
them is we talk with respect and you
yell one day
and give him permission to go ah
right and you go no ice cream for mom
tonight i chose don't have ice cream
because i chose to yell right let him
see that it's not you versus him that
y'all are in this together
and this isn't a
cure-all but this becomes an anchor
point
um
also
if you feel strongly about hey i don't
want to
hit my kid
it's not a bad thing to let your kid
know i'm going to start doing things
differently now
and um
i have i have tried that with him before
and you know
um like doing like you said and you know
letting him know that okay well you know
i'm sorry that you chose this and then i
it's it's more fun when you're out here
with us and when you can play with us
and we all have more fun when you're
here but he seems to be completely
unfazed like if you you know tell him no
dessert with dinner he's like oh okay
well no dessert if you tell him you
can't play with his legos oh well i'll
just twiddle my thumbs or you know he he
seems so unfazed by by everything
there's always you know some sort of
something else he can do instead and so
it's there's twofold to that number one
good for him
he's
he's that's the leadership man he is
learning i'll trade that for that
fair yeah and if it's something of
consequence
right so we're seeing it play on the
global scale we we said if you're you
um country x are gonna bomb this country
then you'll have no more money we're
gonna take all your money
and they go
that's cool we'll keep bombing and then
it's like well okay then you know so at
some point if it's something that we
care about like loss of life you're
gonna keep upping the ante right i will
find something my mom talks about
she locked me in the house like i got
grounded in my room that was hell for me
it was torture
my little brother on the other hand had
to go outside
because he was he liked um reading he
liked he was great with with you know
computer programming he was that kid and
so she had to approach it differently
for both of us but finding things that
were of meaning and a value to us
right um and so that's the that's the
the the navigation apparent but if a kid
decides to ride it out then the kid's
riding it out
and that means we got to up the
accountability a little bit and also
i mean let's high-five your kid that's
kind of cool too right
uh let's start it's so frustrating
because i love it but i hate it there
you go yes yes it's like when my kid
tells a joke and i'm like you can't say
that but that was really funny you know
yes it's like that um some of that is
your kid leaning on you especially in
the season my guess is if y'all are
getting separated now if things been
tough for a season
oh yeah yeah
so has there been any abuse in the home
or anything like that
no no abuse or anything just we just
can't manage to get along what about
volume been yelling and things
uh yeah there has been okay
so
um
in some regard
your kid is gonna double down your kid's
gonna be willing to take um a few lumps
it's gonna bite himself in the foot to
see if you're gonna hang on to him
yeah is he gonna lose you two
and some of that is um making sure he
not only hears you say but sees
you will never lose me
right and um it may be that time outs or
opting out or something like that isn't
the appropriate response for this season
in fact it may be the opposite fine then
if you talk like that you gotta give me
a hug for five minutes an unstopping
five minute hug
you gotta help mom with her laundry
that's just that's what you chose to do
you know what i mean
i'm gonna i'm gonna bring you even
closer to me
um
you have to go draw a picture in this
book about how great mommy is right i'm
gonna i'm gonna do things that are gonna
bring us closer together than the
opposite but the goal here the
overarching thing is this
i want my child to have ownership in
their choices i'm going to teach them
about choices and let's not forget that
they're seven
or they're nine they're 12. they're not
gonna do this perfectly and they will
call our bluff over and over and over
and over again and that's the worst part
of being my mom used to say i promise
you grounding you hurts me more than you
because i can't just leave now because
you're stuck at the house like it's
worse for for me than you um and
sometimes when we're when we are
uh trying to teach our kids
accountability we're trying to teach
them hard work and respect and dignity
all those important things
um
man we gotta we take it on the chin by
holding them accountable
that's the hard dirty work of being a
parent and um man your kid is lucky to
have you natasha
um
be really graceful with him during this
transition it's gonna be hard he's gonna
test every boundary he's got to see if
mom's going to leave
to see if um
there's something he can do that you're
going to say we just can't get along
either i guess or that dad's going to
say well you and i son we just can't get
along so we're done he's going to really
need some extra attention and i would be
direct with your husband about as we
separate here
um if there's no no path for
reconciliation as we separate here
where both of us are going to be
grown-ups about doubling down and making
sure that this little boy this little
baby this little two-year-old are hyper
hyper connected otherwise they will take
this separation on as their problem to
solve and they'll be about solving it
for the rest of their life hey i have a
quick question to jump in with you yeah
so we're talking this makes sense with a
seven-year-old as far as younger kids
like i have a three-year-old when you
talk about
the idea of them
understanding that it's their choice
that they made this choice and they're
dealing with the consequences
it feels like it feels like that's gonna
be hard for a two-year-old or
three-year-old to understand so what
does that look like for a younger kid
yeah sometimes um so james thanks for
that natasha thank you so much for that
call uh james so with a two and three
year old
unfortunately it takes a lot of parent
mobility
meaning i'm going to get up and move you
to this place right you may not be able
to walk away or sometimes it is i will
not allow you to hit right so sometimes
we'll tell a kid um
uh
yeah i'm gonna be more imposing on my
my will if you will um a separation for
a three-year-old is
saying the words out loud
when you hit you chose to go sit over
here and not play i'm not you're not
putting you in another room that's
torture for a three-year-old or a
two-year-old but i will put you over
here and that may mean i have to keep
picking you up and putting you back over
here and we're gonna do the minute per
year right you've heard that um you'll
be in this corner for three minutes and
seeing us
and then the first thing i'm gonna meet
you back there with hugs i'm gonna make
sure you know you're connected please
don't hit please don't choose to go over
here i'm gonna continue to reiterate
that language but you're right
two-year-old doesn't doesn't know that
that where we fall into is we whap a
two-year-old or we swat a three-year-old
and they don't understand that either
and so there's a it's it's that physical
presence but some of that with a
three-year-old is yeah unfortunately i
got bigger muscles than you you i will
not allow you to hit right and i will
move your body once they get to four
five six seven then they start taking
ownership of that i say to my
six-year-old often
i'm please talk to me about why you're
choosing this response here and if she
can't articulate it she begins she'll go
she'll duck her head and then begin to
smile like i don't i don't know you know
what i mean and so i wanted to begin to
take ownership but again
she's six seven
five those are i mean
there's a reason we don't let him vote
hey great question james thanks natasha
we'll be right back
[Music]
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on a camera if you don't want
to it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john daloni show listeners get 10
percent off their first month so decide
to invest in yourself you are worth it
and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey i for the
first time ever i was at my friend's uh
eric this house this weekend and he has
one of those virtual reality headsets i
put it on for the first time
and i had a boxing match
i
punched a wall so hard
i hate it
actually okay so here's the thing it's
incredible let's be honest the
technology is something else like i kept
looking behind me i got all turned
around in the room so much that i
punched to walls trying to hit this
boxer in front of me and
i was getting frustrated anyway the
technology is amazing and i'll also say
when i took that thing off
that's the most disorienting
like i don't know what planet i'm on it
was unnatural i don't know another way
to say it i know i sound like a 100 year
old man who's going up school uphill
both ways in the snow to school
it's something it was so disorienting
you've done it too
yeah my son had his birthday party just
last weekend it was the first time i did
it and i played i actually with boxing i
did the apollo creature yeah yeah that's
what i did yeah um and by the way i hurt
for two days afterwards which is the
worst but i also did the google earth
and i kept having to stop because i
thought i was falling it was so
disorienting oh yeah yeah yeah like you
were about to take a step and yeah they
kept saying john back up and i was like
i can't back up when i actually could
back up but i was up against the ring i
thought i was gonna fall out yeah it's
super disorienting i've definitely hit
walls before i play ping pong in vr and
i've got like a small apartment i'm just
like constantly knocking over mic stands
and stuff in my studio
uh
here's a cool thing man you have an open
invitation to come to my house and
play with a real ping-pong table if you
ever so desire that's awesome all right
let's go to rosalie
the great rosalie in san diego
california what's up rosalie
good morning how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing
i really couldn't be doing better
actually
good good what's up
um well i would like your
expert expert opinion on
if i should um
[Music]
inform my siblings
of my mom's changes in her trust
tell me about this
okay a little background
um i am the youngest of three children
my oldest sibling um has a different
father from
my middle
sibling and i
um
my
uh dad you're wait you're the youngest
of three or oldest youngest youngest
okay yes oh and then your next youngest
sibling the one right above you has a
different dad
no my oldest my oldest sibling has a
different dad okay okay me and my middle
sibling have the same death okay
excellent and we all of course have the
same mom
um
my dad
uh died in 2002. our
my middle sibling and my dad died in
2002. oh man
my
dad
sorry it was a hard worker and he
um built a pretty good nest egg
for him and my mom
my dad my
dad also supported my oldest sibling you
know um
i i don't even remember how old she was
when my mom and dad got married
but um
my dad supported her
you know with
food clothing school you know all that
stuff
um so my dad died in 2002
he
um did not have a will
but he did
put me
on one of his accounts okay his main
account he put me on but when he died
all of his assets rolled to your mom
right correct okay correct everything
went to my mom
um so
after
my dad died i pretty much um my mom was
old school she didn't pay bills she
didn't write checks she didn't
do taxes she my dad said sign here and
she did that was pretty much you know
old school from a long time ago
so my mom
you know did
like what my dad told her to not in a
bad way but just my dad took care of my
mom
so
um
[Music]
everything rolled over to my mom
again she had
my dad incurred assets
not you know he's not a millionaire but
he did very well okay all right so bring
me to now to now um well
the original trust was done in 2012. it
took my mom 10 years to do the trust
so in 2012 she did her original trust
um and she left the house
to my middle sibling
and the assets the money was split
between the three of us that was her
original trust okay
so approximately 2015
my mom started to
talk about changing her trust um
[Music]
i'm pretty much the one who you know did
the bills we you know we had our routine
we went grocery shopping we did our
stuff together and
my
middle sibling
would come around he
um took care of the house
um maintained the house i should say you
know he didn't take care of it but he
maintained the help
um so in about 2015 my mom started
talking about
her wanting to change
the conditions of the trust why'd she
change it
because she knew
that i was the one who was taking care
of her
um she my mom again like i said was old
school when you did something for my mom
she
felt she had booked you back
or right okay so fast forward she's
changed her will and made you the person
over everything right
no okay no
she what she changed
was that she added me to
the house okay
but left the rest pretty much the same
splitting the assets between the three
of us okay that she did
um change
um
you know the ownership of the house so
is your brother under the impression
that whenever she passes away he gets
the house scot-free yes okay
um
why can't she tell
what this sounds like a conversation for
her to have why isn't she not doing that
well um
my mom
knows her children
and she's
she's um knows that if she was to say
anything
that
the middle sibling would probably not
come around anymore
um she wants him to come around this was
like in
2017 is when she finally um
when she
changed her trust yeah but she wants to
have her cake and eat it too
what there's there's something here
you're not telling me is is is mom okay
does mom have no alzheimer's or
something not okay okay
so in 2000 like i said in 2017 she did
the trust and she pretty much told me
you know don't
say anything and
she on her own went to the lawyer
um i did drive her only because she
didn't drive anymore okay
so the lawyer also told me that assets
were moms not mine not my brothers yes
or my sibling correct
so she had the right to do whatever she
wanted to with her asset correct but it
was
it not that it wasn't none of our
business but
tell me about your mom tell me about
your mom
um my mom
is um
does she have cancer does she have
alzheimer's or something she in um
2019 my mom started showing signs of
dementia okay okay um she
this you know at first it was little
stuff and then
in late 2019 my mom um fell
she fell and she hit her head pretty
hard and so the dementia went full force
okay so is um is she so i moved in with
my mom i moved in with her
um in 2019 i moved in permanent with her
okay
um so
fast forward to 2021
um i was diagnosed diagnosed with cancer
i'm sorry um
so my doctor informed me that there was
a good chance everything would work out
good but that i needed to get my affairs
in order
so i did
contact
my mom's attorney
to let him know you know he told me you
have no right to change anything you
have no right to her trust and i told
him i understand that but i just wanted
to inform him
that i might not be in the picture
anymore
if my
counter
progressed
so um
yeah yeah
so hold on
like
get down to your question here what's
the yeah what can i help you with
um
so
i need to my mom always told me
not to say anything what she had done
okay it was her business and
and although i was i wasn't involved
other than taking her i got that i you
don't need to
you need to you need to move past that
in your own heart and mind okay you
drove your mom like you drove your mom
everywhere
um
so here's the thing so now my mom no
longer can make decisions for herself
right she's in a
a rehab facility
okay
um and her dementia is progressing
um she hasn't been able to make
so what can what can i rosalie what can
i help you with
she can't make decisions and choices are
you are you struggling with whether to
tell your brother
yes
okay all right
um
you've mentioned this a bunch so just
give me a yes or no answer
um you've mentioned this you spoke
around it a lot so i just want to poke
right in the middle of it
all right did you play a role in
convincing your mom that you should have
part of the house too because of all the
work you've done
absolutely not okay you are talking
about it as though you have some deep
guilt about it as though you played a
role in taking something from your
brother and if you did not i want to
encourage you to set that brick of guilt
down and never pick it up again
your mom made a grown-up decision with
her grown-up money
and then she unfortunately for you and i
don't ever like to talk bad about
somebody's mom but she did you wrong on
this one
she stuck you in the middle of it and
said you be the person
that holds my lack of integrity
and i hate that she did that to you
but she did and she i'm more um
i'm duty i don't have guilt but i i'm
kind of duty bound to do what my mom
wants me to do you do but you also feel
sick to your stomach over it because
you're lying to your brother
yes i do yes thank you and so
at some point your duty to uphold
someone's lack of integrity is gonna
smack into your
integris heart and your relationship
your honest relationship with your
brother
i agree and so i think um
uh if i'm you does your brother know
about your cancer
yes okay yes um and how is your cancer
by the way you you good
i am good
i'm good i'm uh wonderful my surgery
went well excellent it's so good so i'm
also told not to take care of my mom
anymore for
for six months to a year because of the
extent of my surgery that i can't lift
that kind of stuff so sure it's all good
i'm unable at this time to take care of
my mom
that's that's you've done
great stuff and she's in a home now
where she's getting the rehab care and
the in the daily care that she needs
which is awesome
so i'm you i would not it's not
something you have to do today or in two
weeks or in five months
i would call a sister with i mean a
meeting with all of your siblings
and just say i want to go over both mom
stuff and my stuff
and in that meeting
say
y'all don't know this but mom changed
some stuff in the will
um years ago
and
i just met with her attorney i'm gonna
roll all this out to everybody so we're
all on the same page
and let it just have you have to just
have a grown-up conversation here's what
you don't want to have happen
you don't want your brother
on one weekend to lose his mother if
when she finally passes away
and then also find out that his sister
has been lying to him for however many
years
and also lose a couple hundred thousand
dollars in assets in the same weekend
that's
devastating i agree right
so i don't feel like stole anything but
you absolutely did not you didn't you
didn't steal anything but in his head
mom told him
this house goes to you
right and
so he exhaled and said great
then she changed it on him and didn't
have the courage to tell him because she
wanted him to still think it was his act
like it was his take care of it like it
was his
all the while knowing yeah it's not
really yours
right
and she put it on you
she put it on you to carry that around
agree and that i agree with and that's
the part that's going to haunt you okay
that's going to haunt you and haunt you
and haunt you so
as the i mean
you're the are you the executor of this
estate i'm assuming
um no i'm not good god almighty who's
the executor
my brother
oh jeez louise
well this ought to be fun so you can't
even go to the lawyer and get it he's
got to go get it huh
correct um actually
it's a trust and we're actually all on
the trust and we're all
i'm the medical executor my brother's
financial executor okay um
so how about this to answer your
ultimate question
um in this situation
um yes i think your brother has a right
to know
um
i don't know that it will be
it might be a shape-shifter moment for
your family it might not be um since
he's the executor of the will it might
be important to say hey mom told me that
like years ago she went and
changed some stuff in the will
um that she split the house among
several of us like
i think you should go check on that
stuff as the executor of her estate as
we get here in the last year or two of
her life um go check on that um and as
an executor he can go do that
um that's what i would do if you were
the executor and could walk and i guess
if you're on the trust but i mean again
why would you be dinking around in the
trust if you didn't have something to do
with how it got changed and manipulated
so the whole thing sounds messy and the
whole thing i wish your mom had not have
put you in this situation
um
it wasn't an integrous thing for her to
do she should have called all the kids
together and said hey i'm making a
couple of changes i decided to split the
house up among everybody it's putting
the money up among everybody but instead
she
and again she can do whatever she wants
with her money
but when you do that behind somebody's
back i think the right thing to do is to
tell them by the way i've taken you out
of this
um i'm sorry you're in that situation i
just think honesty in these situations
is the best and it's gonna cause
problems but hear me say the problems
have already been cast right that that
that roll of the dice has already been
thrown um it's just gonna be when y'all
decide to look at the numbers that
rolled up and any time i see something
coming down the road kicking the can is
never helpful and
i'd lean into that as soon as you can i
think your brother deserves that we'll
be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to yo joe
in los angeles california what's up joe
hey john how are you doing man we are
rocking on to the brick of dawn man how
are you
it is a it's a day it's a day it's only
been one of those weeks yes sir it has
it has the world went sideways
um man so what's up how can i help
uh
so uh like lots of folks um trying to
pick up the pieces uh
some
context uh i have i had a brain injury
um a long long time ago uh left me with
some residual damage in my
an associated
disconnects which i think you may know
about um
but
i uh
long story short um
i have a you know very very rare but
very serious when they happen outbursts
that a lot of times people with brain
injuries
do
but what are your outbursts
self-harm
where i'll be hitting myself i will
um
go into like a very what i would
perceive in the moment uh i guess like a
a safe space like a bathroom or a closet
or something and i'll just start like
yelling i'm not yelling but like
repeating um at myself you know very
angry things what um what unwinds you
when you when you
hit that switch what is able to bring
you back
silence um
knowing that
honestly myself uh since my brain injury
i've been to you know
20 plus neurologists psychologists of
course there's family counselors yeah
and i self-administer uh i'm not someone
that says definitely the wrong word i
um definitely go through the process of
even outside of my family helping me
helping myself with doctors and
neurologists and therapists
they have even submitted myself into
clinical trials at different
universities
um a group uh which
um i'm going to leave the name out but
they're pretty well known in the brain
world
right the brain scan world um
been working with them um trying to
narrow down what it is that's causing my
outbursts yeah uh can we
stop for a second i want everybody to
hear this
um
and this is just dude there's just two
guys hanging out in the back of a
tailgate
in a like on the back of a truck in a
parking lot
i
i can't think of a scarier thing in the
world knowing that
at certain moments when i unpredict
unprovoked and and somewhat
unpredictable
my own brain turns on me that's a fear
that very few of us walk through the
world with and man i just want to say
i'm sorry i hate that for you
you know i appreciate that but i
the way my brain works i have a lot of
issues with executive decision making um
which is why i honestly my
the parts of my brain that were affected
were the executive decision making parts
what was that what was the it was the
injury acute what was it
um i i sustained a brain injury after
hitting getting hit by a vehicle um i
was in a coma for a month forgot you
know
a lot of my life uh most of it honestly
before the injury and uh
you know a lot of um memory recall
issues but i also have this savant like
memory
um
storage thing where you know i can i
know it's there the memories are there i
just can't access them but then if i
have a trigger which is you know through
different senses sensories
um those triggers can put me to a near
you know photographic
state of you know being um but the the
issues of me um i i'm i'm in a process a
path you know i'm gonna get better you
know every day gets a little bit
a little better two two steps forward
and the
you know two steps back but at least i
know i can keep moving and eventually
it'll i'll break through through that
but
where my question is is um
man i've been an [ __ ] to my wife um
yeah i don't for some reason i have the
ability to control myself
verbally i've never been a physical
person period for anybody but
i've uh
i've said some mean things in those
moments
the outbursts only happen when i'm with
you know either my family member or by
myself
and again they have like once or twice a
year that i've had this since my injury
that it's like gotten to the point where
i break
but uh
it's unfortunately my wife is usually
present when it happens um
and
i've said uh
i've said things that mean
i mean i'm not gonna
get into details but i've said you know
i called my wife you know [ __ ] and i
said
am i gonna say it on the funnier
yeah but
um
and i don't remember
doing it and i'm not gonna i know i said
it i can't deny it i don't know how to
stop it and it's not things i think of
her i stopped things i
but now i've been living in a hotel for
the last month or a couple of weeks
starting a month okay so she done
it feels like it yeah
when's your most recent outburst
uh
it would have been
about 10 days ago okay and then
i went to the bathroom uh closed i
turned the shower on and started
hitting myself in the head
don't know what happened um
what triggered it i think we had a very
menial argument
and then
yeah i went to the bathroom started like
not hating myself but just like
doing i guess uh
nervous tapping
aggressive tapping i'll say that because
it wasn't i know when i if i hit myself
i've never bruised myself so i'm not
like trying to
kill myself um
in that point or like leave lasting
damage just
something that i do since my injury i
don't know why but so what is your what
is your wife
saying i'm out i'm done
uh i can't live like this
i the quote is i'm not i i can't be
emotionally attached to you and i
understand that yeah she's
not a therapist she's not a psychologist
and i met her when she was you know a
very young adult they're not very young
she's very early 20s and
yeah so man i'm sorry dude
and i don't know
how to
so she lost the guy that she knew right
did she know you pre pre-accident
pre-car wreck no okay wow so she's met
you since then so how long have you all
been together
ten uh decades yeah a decade man decade
we've lived together for seven and we've
been married for three and when did the
outburst begin
um i mean
as far as i i
know they were regular outbursts when i
had my injury i was you know a teenager
um and my parents you know they had like
how many times have you gone after her
like you did the other day
three times
uh the way i did yeah three times i
think
and it's it's it
you know i i had a very good job um very
very good job we're actually a series of
very good jobs uh
and then you know that happened and i
lost the job and i
this is the context that you're missing
or that i think you might not i don't
think i mentioned this but you know i
did try to kill myself um a couple years
ago uh
and i don't ideate anymore like i i know
that i know now because of all the money
i've spent you know
on those scams in my brain that i know
why i id so i know like at least i know
it's not like some part of me that wants
to kill myself it's just in the brain
that's like you know working the right
way there you go and it's overacting and
a part of my brain that is saying hey
hurt yourself kill yourself you don't
belong here sure
but you know
um so has she been able to come back
from that that can be devastating on a
relationship
no um no
it's been a long uh the first
year feeling sorry for myself afterwards
you know not trying to
not try and even recover just
and you know still trying to apply for
work i'm still trying to apply for
different jobs and getting work you know
and i had money saved up after my work
my job that i lost you know we were okay
with money i was able to take trips once
in a while but so bring me bring me down
to how can i help you man you i know you
got so much going on i'm glad that
you're getting the help that you need
and you're surrounded by the best you
know the best experts in the world how
can i help you man
um
you know i've been listening to
the show the last couple days and it's
been honestly giving me the answers i
needed
but i think the first question i had
when i initially called to see if i
could get on the show was how can i save
my marriage like everybody um that are
like so many people but now it's
i i want to save my marriage
but i also want my wife to be with
somebody
not that she has she needs to do
something she's completely
independent woman and she's
so
amazing i watch everything she does
i want i i
i i think i'm just looking for
the
inspiration to help the the the
you know the the the good ending story
where you know they they still are in
each other's lives and
where she can trust me again because
her
a former
partner of hers
did lose his life
that way uh okay so she's got a history
of trauma too and this is a story that
she's seen play out right and in her
mind and her body she knows how the
story ends
and
um
that's terrifying for anybody
here's two things i hear number one she
took herself
or you know you took yourself out of a
situation where i don't want to hurt
somebody that i love and i think that's
noble and good
what makes me uncomfortable is your
language is shifting to
she deserves somebody that and what that
language means is you are starting to
view yourself as a burden to her
and when you do that you know what
happens next
because burden talk
relational burden talk
is the last of the trifecta
of why am i even here anymore people
would be better off if i wasn't here
and so i know you tell me you're done
ideating and all that i don't like the
trajectory of the language you're using
am i on to something or tell me i'm
crazy
you are um okay
so hear me say this
i do think
if you scared your wife
if you yelled and screamed and got in
her face and called her
horrid things
yeah and so and i do want to add i've
you know
everything's a progress everything's
you know and when we first met um again
i've never put my hands on her i never
put my hands on anybody in my life sure
but i i would not i wouldn't understand
certain cues and i would like we would
be getting in a very you know
sometimes loud
we yell each other and because neither
of us who grew up in environments where
people talk to each other like we're
talking now even though like we've both
been working on it sure
but you know i used to not understand
social cues like oh i can't you know
corner my wife in a bathroom so now what
i do is i put my hands up in the air
like i back away so she kind of gets
those cues like i'm not trying to push
you in the corner i'm not sure i'm
trying to make sure you know like
yeah
and i i think i overstepped because i
put myself into a place where i i
look at myself like i'm a mot like this
monster which i've never been a physical
monster i've never been that's right and
listen listen to me listen to me
i'm not i'm not accusing you of that
okay no i know
we're not teddy we don't make fun of
each other we don't poke holes at each
other we we just don't do that sure
she's never ever done that to me she's
never and that and we don't i don't do
that to her like we don't belittle each
other yes she
knows who she married that the person
she married
well she didn't know that that's that's
the problem because i had 10 years yeah
10 years okay so
um
let me which i was very high functioning
that's that's great i should know signs
okay um
but the the reality is here's where we
are okay
i do think
that there is a chance that your
marriage can be saved i think there's a
great chance your marriage can be saved
i also think that in this particular
moment
a little bit of space between the two of
you is a wise thing and that's not
doesn't mean that the thing is over now
and you say things when you are having a
brain a storm is what i've known to call
them the neurological storm when your
brain's trying to talk to itself and
it's not communicating with itself well
and
man when you have those storms
and somebody's on the receiving end of
that it is wise for them to back out
okay that doesn't mean unplug forever
my oldest friend on planet earth the
oldest friend i have
um
has a traumatic brain injury
and i know by the emails i get by the
conversations we have
i'm not even going to respond to this
because he is storming in a way
that makes him think that we are having
a conversation that we had 25 years ago
30 years ago 35 years ago
and my best course of action is to
unplug for a week or two
okay that's the that's the best thing we
do and then i circle back and we're good
and he's got people in his life who love
him and walk alongside him and care for
him and so it's very similar so what i'm
telling you is it is wise and safe and
smart for your wife to back out right
now you scared the crap out of her and
yeah
everybody in this world knows you didn't
do that on purpose
okay
you've you're you're walking through
something i i i
i don't know if i didn't do it on
purpose because i don't recall these
moments happening and here's what i'm
telling you listen to me you didn't do
it on purpose joe
okay
hear me
and i appreciate you saying that but i
also there are other people that are
listening i'm sure that i i want to make
sure folks know that i don't see myself
as a victim whatsoever
quit apologizing you're a good man
you're a good man with some
some major challenges nobody's feeling
sorry for you we're walking alongside
you
you can say right now
i have a very specific question then you
know okay go for it
here's the question
if i truly love someone which i do and i
know that they i think that they love me
still um
how
they i i the first half of our life
together i showed no signs of a brain
injury i was completely normal like
atypical functioning normal person um
and i'd say that you know we're still
normal with eating with brain injuries
it's just a little more difficult all
right so the question you know if
she was not raised in this she doesn't
necessarily have that same foundation in
that support network i do um it's just
true um i have
family i have friends i have people all
over the country that i could go to i
don't
she doesn't necessarily have that same
support group okay give me your question
and she also doesn't have she doesn't
have she doesn't have an education she's
an education and brain um and
you know in neurology she's not a
neurologist she's not she doesn't have
the training and she doesn't necessarily
have the time get to your question
what are you telling me how do i like
how does she deal with me like how does
someone like me like
give her the space and she respect
how does she just deal with me like how
here's how here's how here's how
yeah um your relationship is not special
in this regard
the particular challenge within your
relationship is
but your relationship as a whole is not
it's what me and my wife went through
it's what james and his wife went
through it's what kelly and her husband
went it's what we all go through
which is
i make a decision
to lean in and say i want to know as
much about you as possible
i want to know how i can love you better
what are your turn-ons and not just
sexual what are the things that bring
you peace and joy in your life and what
are the things i can do that contribute
to the offs
everyone has those in their
relationships and the relationships that
make it are the ones that remain curious
as people grow and change which we all
do
when we find out new things when
somebody has been married for seven
years and then they have a daughter and
all of a sudden the trauma of their
sexual abuse as a kid comes flooding
back and nobody saw it coming
and the husband's sitting there going i
don't have any experience with this and
he chooses
to go get counseling himself to go to
marriage counseling to go to trauma
therapy so he learns the words to take a
local community college class for free
or for 350 bucks or whatever it is
to read every book you possibly can to
listen to podcasts like this it becomes
a way of life
because that way of life is love now
here's what i'm going to tell you if you
love her
you will not take her autonomy away to
love you back
that's not love
you can't preemptively say i love you so
much i'm cutting this thing off so that
you can't whatever whatever so that you
don't get whatever whatever you don't
get to do that if you love her love says
i'm going to walk alongside her as she
chooses whether she's in or out
and if she chooses in i'm going to go to
her with with her to the classes i'm
going to go to her uh with her i'm going
to let her come to my appointments with
me so she can begin to learn and get a
context and have the psychiatrist and
the neurologist and all the brain
scientists that are walking alongside
you look at her and say when this
happens
you need to call this number and he
needs to leave the house for a day
that's part of life
it's if if if i have a disorder where if
i eat gluten and i vomit everywhere
if i happen to get gluten and i throw up
all over the house
you know what i mean like i we have a
plan now
whatever that happens to be your plan is
exceptional let's be super clear you've
got a traumatic brain injury that sounds
like it's been with you for a long time
and you are busting your
butt to heal
healing though can't be done in a vacuum
you can't heal by yourself joe you got
to bring her along with you
and you got to tell her i'm deeply sorry
i'm healing you are walking alongside me
from this point forward i'm not doing
this alone anymore we're married we're
in this together
and if she says i'm out that's the
grown-up choice she makes that will be
heartbreaking and devastating and it
does not mean
that it's all on you it does not mean
that somehow you failed you've got
challenges that you have to have
somebody to walk alongside you in those
challenges are they different yeah are
they hard yep
the apology comes as i accidentally hurt
you
in a state of
that was that was directly correlated to
my injury
i cause you hurt and comes i'm
heartbroken i'm so sorry
here's what i'm gonna do to continue to
work to get better please join me in
that
joe listen to me carefully
you're worth love
the world is gonna be worse if you're
not in it the world's better because
you're in it
your fighting spirit and your bravery
will lift up your communities and the
listeners of the show
[Music]
and it's time to stop trying to protect
her as much as allow her to walk
alongside you
allow her to walk alongside you
and keep
grinding keep growing keep getting
better keep getting better keep getting
better we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now's your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be johndaloni.com to start creating
the life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
with some hard calls and some long calls
uh thanks for sticking with us i know
those were tough those were challenging
man so the song of the day is from james
favorite band of all time the smiths the
song is
there is a light that never goes out and
it goes like this
take me out tonight where there's music
and there's people and they're young and
alive driving in your car i never never
want to go home because i haven't got
one anymore take me out tonight because
i want to see people and i want to see
life drive it in your car please don't
drop me home because it's not my home
and i'm welcome no more there is a light
and it never goes out
right here on the dr john dolani show